[موسيقى]
تمتد الى المانيا مطالبه بيديه سته ملايين
بولندي بينما عينه الاخرى ترمق الاراضي
الاوكرانيه فاحذر عدوك مره وصديقك الف مره
كما يقال نعم بولندا تتحين الفرصه وتبحث
عن الوقت المناسب لتستعيد حصتها من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ونحن نتحدث عن بولندا
التي توصف بانها الصديق الاول الذي وقف مع
اوكرانيا ضد روسيا فما كل هذا النكر هو ما
الذي يجري بين بولندا والمانيا من جهه
وبين بولندا وروسيا من جهه اخرى واين
اوكرانيا من كل هذا العقل في حيره من امره
كيف خدعت وارسو كييف وبماذا وعد زينينسكي
نظيره البولندي هي اسئله كثيره وزد عليها
وضع القاره الاوروبيه غير المستقر فماذا
لو اشتعل فتيل التوتر مجددا بين الالماني
البولنديين وماذا لو اندلعت الحرب هل
سيكتفي بوتين بكيس فشار ومقعد بمدرجات
الجماهير ام انه سيقف في صف المانيا متخذا
نظريه عدو عدو صديقي لياخذ حقه من
البولنديين حسنا لقد كثرت الاسئله دعونا
نحكي لكم الوضع باختصار
الماضي وفتيل الازمه الحالي
سته ملايين بولندي قتلوا على يده هتلر
عندما احتلت المانيا بولندا وذلك ما بين
عام
1939 وعام
1945 تم التسويه العاصمه البولنديه
عام
1944 حيث كانت بولندا عباره عن ارض معركه
تعبر منها جيوش هتلر تاره وجيوش السوفيت
تاره اخرى ليعم الدمار والخراب ارجاء
البلاد لكن بولندا لا تتحدث هنا سوى عن
الالبان بقولها احتل الالمان بولندا والحق
بنا اضرارا جسيمه كان الاحتلال اجراميا
ووحشيا الى حد يفوق التصور وترك عواقب لا
تزال في حالات كثيره مستمره حتى اليوم
الغضب البول لم يهدا والحقد يزداد اشتعالا
بمرور الايام بعد ان انتهت الحرب العالميه
الثانيه تدخل الاتحاد السوفيتي وفرض على
المانيا تعويض بولندا بجزء من اراضيها نعم
لقد اعطى جزءا من الاراضي الشرقيه
الالمانيه لبولندا كتعويض عما حل بهم خلال
الحرب ووفقا لوكاله رويتر فقد اعد الحزب
اليمني البولندي احياء دعوات التعويض منذ
توليه السلطه في عام 2015 وجعل الترويج
لكون بولندا ضحيه في زمن الحرب
ركيزه اساسيه لجاذبيته للقوميه الامر الذي
ادى الى صعود موقف عدائي تجاه المانيا
والذي غالبا ما يستخدمه حزب القانون
والعداله لتعبئه جمهوره وارسو لم تتوقف
واوصرت الامر الى الامم المتحده مطالبه
بالتدخل في قضيتها المتعلقه بتعويضات
الحرب العالميه مع المانيا لكن عن اي
تعويضات يتحدثون وها هي الحكومه البولنديه
تقدم تقريرا مفصلا عن الخسائر الماديه
التي عانت منها البلاد خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لتصل المبالغ التي
يطالبون بها الى تريليون واربعين مليار
دولار امريكي فيا لهذا الرقم الفلكي الذي
لا نستطيع حصر عدد الاصفار فيه لترفع
بولندا من حده مطالبها وترسلت تحذير
الاخير الى برلين تطالب فيها التعويض عن
تلك الاضرار بل ان تسلمت الطلب وردت على
الفور وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه بان
القضيه ما زالت مغلقه وان الاتحاد
السوفيتي قد اعفى المانيا من تلك
التعويضات اما البولنديون فلم يغلقوا هذا
الملف ولن يغلقه ابدا ولو كلفهم ذلك اخذ
حقهم بالقوه كما تقول التقارير الغربيه
مطالب ب لا تاتي من العدم فالمانيا عوضت
اسرائيل بمليار و620 مليون دولار على
اقساط ليسيل اللعاب وارسو اكثر فاكثر
فالخسائر البولنديه اكبر من خسائر
الاسرائيليين كما ترى بولندا زعيم الحزب
القومي المحافظ الحاكم
وحزبه يواصلون مهاجمه المانيا حتى
انكازنسكي يزعم ان المانيا تسعى للهيمنه
على اوروبا محذرا من ان البولنديين قد
ينتهي بهم الامر تحت الكعب الالماني وفقا
لاسوشي هولندا تكره وتنتقد كل ما تفعله
المانيا وهي تنتقد باستمرار اعتماد
المانيا على الطاقه الروسيه وخطي
انابيبان لنقل الغاز الروسي الرخيص مباشره
الى المانيا متجاوزين بولندا واوكرانيا
وكانهم يبحثون عن عموله لمرور انا الغاز
على اراضهم اليس كذلك في الحقيقه فالعلاقه
تتداور بشكل مخيف منذ سنوات لتسبب ضررا
حقيقيا وفجوه ناشئه بين شرقي وغرب اوروبا
واوروبا القديمه واوروبا الجديده وهذا
مفيد فقط لبلاديمير بوتين كما يرى
الامريكان مهلا مهلا مهلا في بولندا تخطط
لامر خطير جدا وتتحضر لمواجهه الالمان حيث
تسعى ورسو الى الدخول في خطه المشاركه
النوويه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
البولنديون يريدون من واشنطن نشر قنابل
نوويه من نوع في البلاد وان يتم تدريب
القوات الجويه البولنديه على تشغيلها فضلا
عن مضاعفه التسليح البولندي ومضاعفه
الميزانيه الحربيه وفي حال اندلعت حرب بين
برلين وارسو فالكفتان متعادلتان تقريبا
لكن هناك شخص في الزاويه يضحك ويستمتع
بمشاهده التوتر بين المانيا وبولندا
قايلند هيا هيا فلتبدا باطلاق اول طلقه كي
ادعم احدكما هل عرفتموه نعم انه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عيون بولندا في
احشاء اوكرانيا تعيش الاغنام طوال حياتها
تخاف من الذئب وفي النهايه ياكلها الراعي
هكذا قالها الاولون وهكذا هو حال اوكرانيا
بخوفها الدائم من روسيا بينما تظل بولندا
هي الراعي احدى الدول التي التزمت خطا
شديدا اللهجه ضد روسيا منذ اندلاع الحرب
في اوكرانيا ودعا سياسيون فيها الى بلقنه
روسيا اي تحويلها الى عده ولايات علنا كما
مدت الجيش الاوكراني بكميات كبيره من
السلاح والعتاد على عكس المانيا التي تمد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح لكن على او بعد فوات
الاوان بعض المراسلين العسكريين الروس
يقولون ايضا ان بولندا ترسل الاف المرتزقه
او احيانا الوحدات العسكريه المدربه
للقتال ضد الجيش الروسي في اوكرانيا لكن
اهلا دعونا لا نتسرع بالحكم فقد يكون
للبولنديين مارب اخرى الرئيس الاوكراني
البولنديين حريه الحركه ودخول الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والعمل من دون الحاجه الى
تاشيرات او تشريعات قانونيه هي خطوه شديده
الاهميه نحو احتمالات عوده بولندا لسابق
طموحاتها باستعاده اراضيها في غرب
اوكرانيا التي كان الاتحاد السوفيتي
اقتطعها من بولندا بموجب نتائج الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وذلك بما قد يسمح لاحقا
بتحقيق طموحات العوده لحلمها التاريخي حول
ربط بحر البلطيق في الشمال مع البحر
الاسود وميناء اوديسا على ضفافه في الجنوب
الدعم البولندي لا يتوقف للاوكران باكثر
من خمسه مليارات يورو وطرد دبلوماسيين
الروس وتقديم المساعده لاوكرانيا
واللاجئين ليتضح ان ذلك ليس حبا باوكرانيا
ولا كرها لروسيا بل ان لعب بولندا يسيل
لاستعاده الاراضي التي فقدتها عقب نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه خطه بولندا بشان
غرب اوكرانيا لم تعد سريه منذ فتره طويله
والعالم باسره تقريبا يعلم ان بولندا تخطط
لاعاده اراضيه التاريخيه وهذا ليس كلامنا
ولكنه تقرير لصحيفه زينيكا البولنديه التي
قالت ان وارسو بدات بالفعل مرحلتها الاولى
ادخال الكتيبه البولنديه الى اوكرانيا
كمرتزقه اجانب ومعظمهم من النساء الاف
الجنود البولنديين في اوكرانيا في المناطق
الغربيه بمبرر الشرطه
وينتشر جنود البولنديون اخرون ايضا في
الجنوب الاوكراني ليشاركوا في المعارك
يتصاعد الخلاف بين المانيا وبولندا بشكل
مستمر خصوصا بعد رفض وارسو نشر صواريخ
باتريت على اراضيها لقد يهدد وحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى بعد ان انحرف
صاروخ اوكراني عن مساره وقتل مواطنين
بولنديين خلال الفتره الماضيه تواصل وارسو
تعنتها ورفضها لكل ما هو الماني وعلى
العكس تماما تقدم بولندا اثمانا باهظه في
اوكرانيا والسبب كما قلنا لكم سابقا
ابتلاع واستعاده الاراضي من اوكرانيا التي
فقدتها في الحرب العالميه فهل تقول كييف
خذوا ما شئتم ولكن ساعدونا في صد القوات
الروسيه
[موسيقى]